If you look in
the GifEditorViewController in the
Objective-C project you'll notice that
there's a property for a gifImageView.
Go ahead and add this property in your
GifEditorViewController.swift file,
and connect it to
the gifImageView in Storyboard.
We're also going to add
a property to hold the gifURL and
that property will be
an optional of type NSURL.
We'll set it to nil for now.
Once you've got the gifURL set up,
we're going to want to add some
code to the method viewWillAppear.
This code will render
the gifURL as a gif.
Kind of like we did in
the WelcomeViewController,
we'll make a GIF from the recording
by calling the method gifWithURL.
And notice that gifWithURL
takes a string as a parameter.
So we'll need to use the absoluteString
property of our NSURL.
And then we'll load that
image into the gifImageView.
And, of course, let's not forget
to call super.viewWillAppear.
With these life cycle methods, we
always have to remember to call super.
Back in our
UIViewController+Record extension,
we'll instantiate an instance of
the GIF editor, add our GIF URL and
then push that on to
the navigation stack.
We're going to do all of that
in a method called displayGIF.
So first we instantiate our
GifEditorViewController,
pass it the gifURL and
then push it on to the navigation stack.
And, of course,
we'll want to call the method displayGIF
from the method convertVideoToGIF so
that we can pass it the gifURL
we just got from regift and
we won't forget to unwrap it.
We're also going to need to call this
convertVideoToGIF method somewhere,
we can do that up in
didFinishPickingMediaWithInfo.
Remember we were just saving
the video to the photo album,
instead we'll just
call convertVideoToGIF.
And now we'll run it.
So let's see how it looks.
Here comes the camera, there's my
video producer seeing how many malt
balls he can stuff in his mouth, the
camera dismisses and there's our GIF.